I must say when we decided together to
have the values Summit on the 31st of
January we had no clue that it would
coincide with the
commemoration of uh jacqu delore
basically the founder or initiator of
the values uh social dialogue and it was
here in this very Castle on the 31st of
January in
1985 that Jack La uh explained his
vision for social dialogue in for the
future of the European Union and he
believ very strongly that there could
not be a United Europe without a Europe
that is built on social dialogue and he
is so right we know today by experience
we know that um we are stronger and
better when we have in our economy the
social market and thus the social
Partners just let me give you three
examples that you all uh witnessed the
first was the time during the pandemic
and when the first lockdowns started we
together developed for the very first
time on the European level the sure
shorttime employment where we all stood
together we made sure that uh employers
did not have to lay off their employees
when the lockdowns were there and there
were no orders anymore but they stayed
thanks to European commitment in the job
and with that we kept the skills and the
knowledge in the jobs and therefore at
the end of the lockdowns um immediately
our companies could take the orders
because they had the skills and the
people in place in their companies the
second topic um that I would like to
recall is our discussions on the EU
directive on minimum wage and how much
we shaped it together because we're
deeply convinced that the basis must be
the bargaining the collective bargaining
in the member states and I think the
final product is good because we had the
social
dialogue my third um example is our
approach how we Implement our policies
and here I would like to look at the
European green deal over the last years
we have basically formed the road map or
described the road map and formed the
legal framework but now it's about
implementation and we know that
implementation has to be tailor made and
here we have started our industrial
dialogues together with you to make sure
that uh yes we share the same goal but
how we get there has to be tailor made
for each industrial ecosystem the same
is with the structured dialogue we have
now in agriculture that together we
Define how we're going to reach our
goals in the future and what this
different scenarios are
so I think this is the Hallmark of our
social market economy and um this is the
reason why we're here today the world is
changing
rapidly um and if we look at the clean
transition we see basically the changes
in front of our doorstep if you look at
the United States massively investing in
clean technology through the inflation
reduction act if you look at China
massively subsidizing electric vehicles
that come to our Market but also look at
the Gulf States who are basically
sitting on oil and gas but investing in
clean hydrogen because they know these
are the energies of the Futures future
and they want to dominate the market
with these energies of the future
too um so for us is important that we
push forward in the social dialogue um
when shaping our economy because we must
on one hand keep the Competitive Edge
and on the other hand we must make sure
that nobody is Left Behind and this goes
only if uh we are working together so
today we are taking important steps
forward um we commit to each other to do
our part to address one of our key
challenges facing our economy that is
labor and skills
shortages the commission will present an
action plan that we will prepare very
closely with you we have started the
discussion already and we need all the
knowledge that is out there and all the
best practices to be successful in that
field and that leads me to The Reason
Why We Gather here today in values we
must consolidate the progress that we
have made so far we must make sure that
this method continues to drive the work
of the European institutions in the
years to come
and therefore the values declaration
that we signed today is a commitment to
work side by side to strengthen the
social dialogue and to join forces to
address the key challenges of our time
the commission will create a European
social dialogue Envoy within the
commission so that you have a point of
contact so that the connection is tied
and close because so much things so many
things are happening one person as point
of contact I think is um excellent for
this common
Endeavor most important of all the
commission will uh launch a joint
declaration process that will lead to a
PCT for European social dialogue this is
work to do ahead of us but we want to do
it together and let me site at the very
end of my opening remarks of course
jacqu
delore who said about the social
Partners Le for Vi DEET this is how we
called you as one of the main drivers of
European integration 40 years later this
is still true so uh we have a lot ahead
of us um a very warm welcome again to
all of you um I'm very glad that we have
the combination of events today now the
social Summit
afterwards the commemoration for jacqu
theore and with that dear prime minister
I would like to give the floor to you
thank
you well thank you dear uh dear Ula
Madame President for for these opening
remarks and and for convening this uh
social Partners uh Summit maybe first of
all about this historic uh location
vales one could say that this place
breeds uh Europe This was the place
where the Treaty of Rome was was
negotiated if you would walk around in
this building down there there is a
plaque that uh that that shows us this
was the basis of the negotiations on the
uh on the common market and then as you
said Ursula 40 years ago sh delor
brought together the social Partners
here to really bring new life to what
was at that point the common market and
to make it the uh the single market and
he did that by bringing together uh
trade unions and business organizations
to to discuss the the the heart of that
uh of that construction so I guess it is
with a certain degree of humility that
we are here today this building also has
been used by a lot of Belgian
governments for Budget
negotiations and those were not always
as glorious as the discussions we will
have we will have here um uh our single
Market as being said it is really the
basis of the the prosperity the
competitiveness the growth and I would
also say the security that we have have
in in in in Europe it is what sets us
apart on the world stage it is that
group of 440 million people who say we
are not alone we are Partners it is that
what really makes us um gives us
influence on the on the world stage and
and I think we really should say that
the single Market is a is is a great
success a lot of work has been done but
as always there is still a lot of work
to be done in in the world of today
where you have major uh disruptions you
could almost say that like 40 years ago
it is similar challenges with which we
are confronted as then geopolitics is is
more important than ever um Global free
trade is no longer a a given and you
have new technologies such as AI which
are uh which are providing opportunities
but also let's be clear some uh some
clear challenges and for employers and
for employees which could have
far-reaching consequences if we do not
tackle them in the right way if we do
not organize it in the right way climate
change obviously also um has made is is
one of the biggest Endeavors which we uh
which we have our challenge to
decarbonize our economies forces us to
uh transform our economies at at a high
Pace um and and let's be clear could put
the cohesion in our societies under uh
under pressure demographics are changing
rapidly just in the domain of care in
the broad sense the the the uh the needs
are are gigantic and and and we need to
be able to cater to uh to uh to that um
in this context the need for skilled
workers has never been so high the need
for finding the right balance between
work and uh and life and finding the
quality of life has never been more
strongly felt than in our in our
societies and I think we should also say
that another aspect is is is very
important that is social stability
social stability is the Cornerstone of
democratic societies and the social
dialogue has always played a key role in
uh in in nurturing that social uh that
social stability um all of that is in
the priorities of the Belgian uh Belgian
presidency
um we cannot do that in
isolation um social Partners throughout
Europe have an essential role to play
together with governments of course and
personally I'm convinced that a
strengthened and a revitalized social
dialogue is the way forward for uh
common success after all it is the
social Partners who know best what's at
stake in companies who know best what's
at stake in the European uh labor market
and so near urula under your leadership
pleased to bring together to social
Partners to reflect on what is required
and what are the priorities in the next
institutional uh cycle I'm convinced
that the discussion today will provide
us with valuable insights uh should help
us in sketching out what the priorities
should be in the next year so so there
therefore on behalf of the council the
Belgian pres presidency fully supports
the engagement outlined in the vales
declaration IT addresses the imminent
need for labor and skills shortages
while enhancing engagement between
social partner and the the European
commission putting again workers and
businesses small and large at the
rightful place and the rightful place is
really at the heart of the discussion at
the heart of the actions that we take
for a a common future and a common
future is a future that gives
perspective for everyone that provides
the security that is uh that is
necessary and that uh that helps us in
uh in further strengthening a European
Union that is at the service of our
populations thank you thank you very
much um now I would like to uh give the
floor to you Fric
person thank you so much dear president
dear prime minister dear
[Music]
deputy